did you know that the Dragon Ball Z
movies got a pretty remarkable remaster
release a few years back and did you
also know that someone took a big fat
juicy piss all over them these HD
blu-ray releases of the Z movie sourced
from HD Masters came out a few years
back and as far as visual Fidelity goes
they were a huge step up in terms of
clarity you could see the individual
specs of dust on the line Ard it was so
crisp and clear but alas toy did their
trademark toy thing and didn't really
pay much attention to the actual
remastering process process and the end
result was a release that had great
Fidelity but was well drenched in Piss
of all colors in fact some of them were
green piss some of them were red piss
all the colors of the piss rainbow were
applied to these releases there was no
discrimination thankfully fans
immediately took to manually color
correcting the mistakes and it proved
that these releases didn't have to be
this way but like why can I not go out
and buy just one one good Dragon Ball
Blu-ray release why